اتحول الى الاستاذ ساري رابي الكاتب
والباحث السياسي في رام الله استاذ
ساري بالنظر لما جاء في بيان حماس وحديث
رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري عن رد
ايجابي كما قال
لحماس هل يعني ذلك ان مصير الصفقه الان هو
في الملعب
الاسرائيلي وبالتالي كيف ستكون النقاشات
الاسرائيليه وفي ظل هذه التباينات داخل
معسكر نتنياهو والمناورات ولاءات
التي قالها
بلمس يعني اولا انا اعتقد ان مفتاح كل ما
يجري هو التصريح الصريح من وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي والمفيد في الوقت نفسه حينما قال
بصوره صريحه ومفيده في الحقيقه ان كان ثمه
رهان ان تستسلم حركه حماس وان تسلم سلاحها
وان تطلق الاسرى الاسرائيليين الذين لديها
من موقف الهزيمه والتنازل والاستسلام ولكن
لان ذلك فاشل فكان لا بد من البحث عن مسار
جديد هذا المسار هو جهود التهدئه هذه
الجاريه الان والتي قال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انها جهود يراد لها ان تستمر
لفتره اطول وحينما سئل عن وقف اطلاق النار
قال ان الامور لا تاتي مره واحده حينما
سئل عن ضغطه على اسرائيل او لماذا لا يضغط
على بنيامين نتنياهو قال ان الامور لا
تاتي مره واحده وهذا اعتقد حجر الزاويه
والعنصر الحاسم في هذا الموضوع وهو صمود
المقاومه الفلسطينيه داخل قطاع غزه وصمود
الشعب الفلسطيني والمجتمع الفلسطيني داخل
قطاع غزه فشل ليس فقط الرهان الاسرائيلي
ولكن الحقيقه فشل الرهان الامريكي في
امكانيه كسر حركه حماس وكسر المقاومه داخل
قطاع غزه وكسر الشعب الفلسطيني داخل قطاع
غزه والدفع نحو مشروع التهجير من داخل
قطاع غزه هو الذي بات يدفع الاداره
الامريكيه للبحث بصوره ح حثيثه عن مخرج
الجديد ينزل بنيمين نتنياهو عن الشجره
وربما يوفر ارضيه سياسيه لنقاش مختلف لم
الات ومصير هذه الحرب هذا ابتداء وهذا امر
يقودنا في الحقيقه الى حركه حماس والفصائل
الفلسطينيه في مقابل الاداء والسلوك
الاسرائيلي تجاه هذا الموضوع وتجاه هذا
الملف الاسيه اب الا عفوا عفوا قبل ان
تاتي الموضوع الاسرائيلي فيما يتعلق بحماس
هل الحديث عن ان حماس قدمت ملاحظات وليست
شروط هل يعني ذلك بانها رساله من حماس
بانها لا تريد ان تكون سببا في
عرقله اتفاق الاطار ما
رايه الحقيقه موضوع متداخل يعني لا يوجد
انفكاك عن طبيعه الموقف الاسرائيلي
والمناوره الاسرائيليه واللعبه
الاسرائيليه واداء قياده حماس وقياده
المقاومه الفلسطينيه على هذا الصعيد
بنيامين نتنياهو في الحقيقه يريد ان يمسك
بكل شيء في وقت واحد يعني بمعنى يريد ان
يبقي تحالفه وائتلاف على حاله ويريد ان
يمضي بهذه الحرب فتره اطول ولكنه يريد ان
يقول لاهالي الاسرى ولهذا التحول في
الشارع الاسرائيلي المتصاعد والمتنامي
والذي يطالب باعطاء اولويه لملف الاسرى في
سياق هذه الحرب العدوانيه على الفلسطينيين
في قطاع غزا انه يبذل جهوده على هذا
الصعيد ولكن التعنت ياتي من حركه حماس
حركه حماس ارادت ان تقطع هذه اللعبه وهذه
المناوره على بنيامين نتنياهو بالتاكيد
اتفاق الاطار المعلن عنه حتى هذه اللحظه
هو لا يلبي لا مطالب حركه حماس ولا مطالب
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ولا مطالب الشعب
الفلسطيني داخل قطاع غزه ولكن حركه حماس
بالنظر الى مجموعه من الاعتبارات الاعتبار
الاول انها بالفعل تريد وقف اطلاق النار
ولا تريد من الاسرائيلي في سعيه لتجريد
المقاومه الفلسطينيه من ورقه الاسرى
الاسرائيليين لدى المقاوم الفلسطينيه ان
يعود من جديد الى استهداف الشعب الفلسطيني
داخل قطاع غزه وفي مراحل تاليه ابتزاز
الفلسطينيين في قضيه الاعمار ورفع الحصار
هي بالتاكيد تريد ان تعيد صياغه هذا
الاتفاق او ان تضع تفاوضا على هذا الاتفاق
بالفعل بحيث يضمن وقف اطلاق نار في
النهايه ولكنها ايضا في المقابل تنظر الى
الحاجات الجاريه والانيه والماسه
للفلسطينيين داخل قطاع غزه بسبب الماساه
والكارثه الانسانيه التي اقترفها الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بحق الفلسطينيين داخل قطاع غزه
ومن ثم هي هي توائم بين هذين الاعتبارين
وفي الوقت نفسه تريد ان تقطع لعبه بنيامين
نتنياهو الذي يحاول ان يقول لاهالي الاسرى
والشبكه الاجتماعيه المتنا المتناميه حول
اهالي الاسرى داخل اسرائيل ان المشكله
ليست من عنده ولكن المشكله من عند حماس
ايضا تريد حركه حماس في الحقيقه ان تقوي
المواقف التفاوضيه الوسيطه التي يوم بها
الجانب المصري والتي يقوم بها الجانب
القطري من الجهه المصريه معروف تماما
التهديدات الاسرائيليه التي تتحدث عن
احتلال محور فيلادلفيا او التوجه بهجمه
بريه حربيه على الفلسطينيين داخل معبر رفح
تريد حماس بالتاكيد تقويه الموقف المصري
الرافض لذلك ايضا تريد حركه حماس تقويه
الموقف القطري كلنا نعلم ان كان هناك
محاوله اسرائيليه ومحاوله امريكيه لعزل
حركه حماس ووصفها بانها داعش الى اخر ما
قيل في بدايات هذه الحرب ومن ثم تسعى حركه
عماس بالحقيقه ايضا الى قطع اي محاوله
لعزلها وتشويهها من خلال تقويه مواقف
الاطراف التي تتحدث معها وتكون بدور
الوسيط ازاءها مثل ال الموقف القطري ايضا
حركه حماس في الحقيقه حريصه على جمله من
الاعتبارات على هذا الموضوع هذا الموضوع
لا يخص حركه حماس وحدها يخص المجتمع
الفلسطيني داخل قطاع غزه هناك شركاء لحركه
حماس ورفاق درب ورفاق خندق لحركه حماس
داخل قطاع غزه ايضا من المهم ان يكون هناك
تشاور معهم ومن ثم في هذا الرد ليس رد
حركه حماس وحدها وانما هو رد مجمل فصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه ايضا اظهرت حركه كذا
قال ك هكذا قالت كما جاء في البيان ان هذا
الرد جاء بالتشاور مع الفصائل الفلسطينيه